we live in a culture that seems very
averse to even having any
regrets I I blame myself for drinking I
blame myself for being like friendly
with the guy and I didn't want to tell
my mom because I felt like she would be
ashamed if you see the way that they
talk about women being sexually
assaulted imagine if you're a man who's
gone through that and how hard it would
be for you to come forward it's a weird
thing that social media has done where
everyone is pretending to be empathetic
but actually everyone's a [__]
psychopath Bridget so awesome to have
you back on the show so great to be back
uh we love you you're one of the
funniest people online and offline
frankly you're one of the funniest
people is what I'm trying to say thank
you uh but you're also a brilliant
writer and a very uh very serious writer
you wrote this article that
absolutely destroyed the internet as far
as I could tell which was called I why I
regret or was it I regret I regret being
a SL I regret being a [__] there's no
why there's no why cuz everybody
knows why did you write it tell tell
everybody what the core of it is why you
wrote it and we'll we'll talk about it
yeah I wrote it uh I've been trying to
write it for a long time so it's an it's
a piece I think since 2018 that i' had
been wrestling with and I could never
really thread the needle in a way that
felt like I wasn't [__] shaming
everyone I had to really make it about
me because I don't care what other
people do and who they sleep with and
whatever I was only trying to talk about
my own experience um just how I felt I'd
been kind of lied to by the culture and
internalize so many of those lies myself
like
basically can I swear of course you
[__] can so the idea that I could
[__] my way to empowerment this idea
that you know you can sleep your way to
feel feeling feeling like a girl boss or
feeling confident and coming from trauma
and having addiction that generally
wasn't the case but I kept doubling down
because I think I was trying to cope
with feelings of Shame and worthlessness
and it was complicated too because I had
so much stuff around sex being raised
Catholic so the messaging I was raised
with was very guilt infused around
sexuality and feeling guilty about
having sex or even thinking about sex
sometimes and re kind of rebelling
against that and then really embracing
that this very modern idea of just and
the reaction to a lot of this kind of
religious
puritanical ideas of just being a proud
[__] and I was
um I I don't know how much of it I
actually believed in my Quiet Moments
alone and then when I got sober I really
had to look a lot of the damage I caused
to kind of My Soul and Spirit directly
in the face as uncomfortable as that was
and that led me to kind of wanting to
write this piece because I saw so many
so many women on just dating and online
and it seems like they they might not
feel like they want to sleep around but
there's this kind of pressure to just be
like I'm okay with just having sex you
know with whomever and maybe they they
aren't and wondering
if I don't know they're
making they're making decisions maybe
for the for reasons that they're not
totally in touch with which is what was
the case for me so I could again only
kind of speak for myself but yeah it was
a it was something I really people when
I wrote it were like oh you wrote this
cuz you're married and everyone feels
differently after they have a kid and I
was writing this before I ever got
married was in a relationship or had a
child so these feelings were were
surfacing way before any of that and the
cultural lie you talk about is the idea
that sex with casual sex with lots of
people is empowering liberating for a
woman yes yeah which for some people
that might be true you know there's many
people who they they feel confident in
that and they love it and and there were
probably times where I did I I'm not
saying that all of my my casual sex was
horrible and regretful it's just that I
think for
me I can't came from I was trying to
kind of heal trauma using sex which is
not something I
recommend to people who might be in a
similar position you know I just I think
that there was a lot of Shame after I
was raped when I was SE
18 uh and I didn't really know how to
cope with it and some people respond to
sexual assault um by being hyper
promiscuous
and some people go the other way and I
happen to kind of lean into alcoholism
addict I mean I don't think it's an
accident that I ended up in rehab a year
after that happened to me and I still
ended but there was also just this
desire to feel like I had some kind of
power and control and I think as a woman
you do have a lot of power particularly
in those super hot years of your late 19
to like 25 when you're I look at
pictures of myself then I'm like I had
no idea how hot I was I mean I knew I
had sexual power but I didn't it's like
you get this Corvette and you're you
don't know how to drive it you're that's
the the weirdest thing about becoming
coming into your sexuality for me as a
woman was I could not I literally could
not wear the color red when I was in
those a i it was like
too too powerful of a color for me to
wear with that much
sexual
um energy and appeal yeah yeah and I
didn't I didn't know how to wield it at
all it was or like having a lightsaber
that I was like I don't know what to do
with this and I did whatever I wanted
but um I don't think I always felt great
about it if I was really because there's
this question am I just rewriting is
this just historical revisionism am I
just looking back and now feeling that
way but at the time I was like hell yeah
and I think at the time I was like hell
yeah but I don't know that I believed
that 100% because I know there were Ms
many many mornings of feeling shame and
I mean I remember one time I had to wake
up and drop a pin to figure out where I
was you know that's and a lot of it is
addiction too which I think complicates
this uh somewhat is that I don't know
that I would have been as promiscuous
had I also not
been a crazy alcoholic
so there's there's that piece too that I
couldn't you know delve into in the in
the piece I wrote but that's a big part
of it and so looking back I know I know
there was I just had so many mornings of
feeling sh ashamed and feeling used that
feeling of being discarded oh
I just see I have so many girlfriends
now dating and I see what they go
through and I see how how much it hurts
them to not hear from someone if they
sleep with them or I don't know it's
it's tough out there yeah it is tough um
here's another way of looking at it
William Blake had a saying that the
Palace of wisdom was re is reached
through the gates of
excess and actually
maybe a way of looking at it and
reframing it might be the fact that okay
you had all these experiences which you
look back on but maybe you shouldn't
regret it and maybe it's given you a
deeper understanding not only of who you
are but what you want from life I mean
that's true what was interesting to me
too is this
default the reaction to the piece was
really interesting I've been get I still
get emails from it from Men Women gay
men I heard from a lot of gay men and
the
one of the more interesting things that
I wasn't expecting was people's
resistance to my use of the word regret
we live in a culture that seems very
averse to even having any regrets you
know that's kind of like
YOLO um I and I don't know if this is a
cultural thing but I I feel okay with
having regrets I think it's I think it's
part of life I do think you learn from
them I don't think you should let them
hold you hostage and I don't live in
regret but looking back there's many
reasons I regret this too it's not just
because of what I feel it did to my own
spirit and Soul at the time and having
to doing more damage to myself than was
already done I also regret that some of
these guys can say they had sex with me
like it's a from a purely egotistical
point of view I don't like that the
first time I ever went on Rogan I got so
many text messages and I was like oh
like it it was probably the beginning of
me thinking about writing this piece
because someone texted me and they said
um it was a man I'd had like a fling
with it wasn't even a one night stand I
think it was in another country too and
he texted me he was Australian of of
course
um um and and he texted me and he was
like I I'm super happy to be able to say
I was in somebody who is on Rogan and
was
like and that's why you should never
date in Australia and that's I do stand
up about this I don't I don't ever want
to hear from women if they're dating
rock stars Comedians and Australian you
lose the right to like cry to me um no
but that that was you know and there
were many of those there was not not
hundreds but there were there were
enough that it made me feel disgusting
and um also just like [__] I don't want
that guy to be able to say that just
point to his buddies and be like I
shagged
her use of a British word I'm only using
shag because I'm with you guys I do love
that word it is a great word it is a
great word and somehow not as offensive
exactly and slightly more playful like
if you say [__]
like yeah that's kind of nice takes the
edge off
I was trying to take the edge off
because but it's so interesting to hear
you talk about this because we live in a
culture where promiscuity is celebrated
yeah you know where we say there's no
difference between women and men we can
all go out and enjoy casual sex and to
be brutally honest with me I never I've
had a few one night stands I've always
found them lonely and dispiriting
experiences I don't think enough people
realize that even if you know know males
and females are wired differently and
men are able to sleep with more people
have less social cost have I see even in
all the emails I've received from men
they have a cost too it doesn't always
like you said it doesn't always feel
good for them either even even getting
sober the difference in male and female
um meetings when you kind of there's
still a difference what's the difference
you looked at me like there's a there's
a different no I'm just kidding um they
the difference I think women have a lot
of Shame about what has been what
they've done what's been done to them in
many instances men seem to have a lot of
Shame about what they've done they've
done to not not necessarily what's
happened to them what they've done to
other women how they've treated other
women so it seems very different to me
that and that's just what I've gathered
from talking to men about the different
why they love going to men's you know
recovery meetings is just because they
can talk about different things in a way
that they can't when there are women
around in the same way that women can
share about stuff that
is very specific to the female
experience particularly when you are
doing drugs and drinking that maybe men
can't relate to or are part of their you
know problem and Trauma and whatever
ever so yeah I think it's it's been um
that piece is still going I just didn't
I did I had a podcast with the ASA jeu
podcast hosts and they were saying one
of the woman women hio was telling me
that she gives it to her students and I
have had so many parents reach out to me
who have young young you know 20
something College age women and they're
saying they send it to them and say they
have their daughter read it
I have people with young you know
teenage girls and they reach out to me
and ask me they're like I don't know if
my daughter should read this and it's
very interesting having a daughter now
and having that out there because I
don't know if my daughter should read it
either yeah um but she will eventually
well she's only what 16 months 17 months
your daughter she's pretty much 16 years
old though
I a she's she's she's really quite uh
got quite a mind of her but also I think
it's you know it's crazy how fast it
goes she's going to be 16 and it is in a
blank in the blink and I'm grateful that
I have the opportunity to talk to her
about these things but it's those are
going to be interesting conversations oh
for sure I found you know when we're
talking about this
and when the russal brand allegations
broke and
look firstly just to clarify yeah you
know it's you nobody knows about apart
from change we were just talking about
motherhood
Russell and Russ but not necessarily the
allegations but the reaction to the
allegations I found even more
interesting you know how people were
just like you know he's guilty and the
other people who many of whom never even
knew about Russell or about the
allegations and may not even have read
immediately were just like oh you know
it's the women and blaming the women
yeah and I just found that so
interesting and there was kind of a sub
current which is actually what I want to
talk about is these women were
promiscuous therefore they kind of
deserved it I mean that's a very '90s
late 9s mid ODS when you look at um
pamel Lee Anderson and why the judge
basically threw out the they said that
essentially because she was in Playboy
and it already showed her body when that
tape got released she the judge said oh
well you're already out there so it's
not violating at all which is insane and
crazy to me but that that idea of you
know she's asking for it is not that's
the other funny thing about the weird
modern like whatever the discourse is
right now it's insane and it feels very
extreme but there does seem like there's
this rise of misogyny there's a lot of
Body Count talking going on and I don't
think it's it's very weird but like all
these guys who are doing this are acting
like they invented [__] shaming I'm like
you guys like this has been around you
know you aren't inventing some new thing
this is like the oldest tale of time
around women and the stuff I reacted
very strongly to the to the way that
particularly people with large platforms
automatically came out and just defended
Russell Brand before they'd even heard
the allegation right that was so weird
just like you haven't even seen what
he's being alleged you don't even know
yeah and I have and then when I came out
and said you know I pushed back against
this I got kind of piled on and people i
i people act like I didn't extensively
right about this is the downside of
believe all women we're going to pay a
cost for this in the future here we are
the chickens have come home to roost and
now it's just there's no such thing as
no allegations are to believe well this
is what I said at the about me too it
was everyone seems to not everyone but
the vast majority of people want
everything to be black and white and
it's like what happened to Aziz Ansari
was an Abomination yeah what happened to
Harvey Weinstein who's against that
right who who who regrets that that
happened right who who who are the
people people that think that was a bad
thing that happened har Weinstein's
accountant right probably right apart
from him like do you see what I mean but
we no definit we have lost the ability
to have that nuance and and it's
something that we lost during me too
which was why women like myself who were
coming from the left it was one of the
things that pushed me you know sent more
Center saying okay we'll do processes
necessary we can't have these witch
hunts they're going to backfire the
Kavanagh stuff drove me insane because
the Democrats I'm like you guys have
gone from using women to Now using
sexual assault you're weaponizing so I
came of age around Monica Linsky and
that was the first time that I really
was like Wow neither party gives a [__]
about women I remember I was five years
younger than her so I was close in age
to her and I remember every all the
adults in the room were talking about
the politics of it and how this whatever
side they might have been on how this
played out I was like what about this
poor girl she's being piled on by you
have the you know Hillary Clinton
basically throwing her under the bus and
you have all the right wing using should
have her own mom had to testify against
like they called her mom to testify that
is that is insane to me it was it was
heartbreaking from a p i remember that
was a very specific moment and it was
shortly after I had been sexually
assaulted that I really checked out of
politics and was like no one's coming I
don't care um and I think everyone's
gross I actually have been thinking so
much about this because I really believe
that was the beginning of that internal
sense of politically homeless that
drives everyone crazy but I'm like I
can't help how I feel this is just how I
feel and then um the kavana stuff drove
me crazy because it reminded me so much
of that but then I felt like they were
weaponizing sexual assault and it got
more and more ridiculous you had that
douchebag whatever that lawyer was
avanetti coming out and saying he was
gang it just it was so undermining to
the whole entire process and it made
people not and again you had kind of
people on the right wing going talking
about you know being like defaulting to
rape apologists immediately because they
fighting against this ridiculous kind of
um idea that you need to believe all
women and I was like this is not going
to be good in the long run and now here
we are and you have huge people with
lots of followers just coming out in I
mean I think Elon even came out in
defense of him before I'm like you are
the richest man in the world you have
are the owner of the platform that this
discourse is taking place on you didn't
need to say anything but you said I
stand with Russell and how then you
wonder why women don't come out and and
and report and they don't they don't
come forward because lots of women still
don't and it's just it feels like we're
going
backwards hey Francis do you want to
protect your privacy of course I do now
that I'm an international celebrity
who's appeared on hit shows like The Joe
Rogan Experience I have to protect
myself from vicious people looking to
tear me down I'm the Michael Jackson of
the internet not the celebrity I would
have gone for but trust is important
when picking a VPN I don't trust anyone
after she left me she took everything
Francis remember what your lawyer said
good point you can trust expressvpn
because they don't sell sell your data
to advertisers they've even created
software called trusted server that
means they can't store any data at all
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to
disintegrate loads of people are saying
that expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals ra expressvpn as the
number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with Express
VPN use our link
expressvpn.com trigger toay and get an
extra three three months free on a
one-year package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com SLT trigger to learn more
she took
everything the one thing that I wanted
to touch on as well that the thing that
I found most depressing and dispiriting
about the whole thing was just then
there was a The Narrative would always
been bubbling under if you're
promiscuous you deserve it and then it
became overt and then what people
started saying is you know you can't
settle down with a woman who has being
promiscuous because she has this she is
unable to and their term pair bond and
you're going mate you're you're a
[__] with Twitter followers are you
a psychiatrist have you done research
and but it's but then they all start
sharing it and I go and these are some
of these people I know and I used to
respect and and I think to myself what
is going on I went into a very dark
depression after all of this it was
really upsetting to me because perhaps
being I think being rejected by the left
as we talked about on the last podcast
and that we did and really coming
feeling like I was tribess maybe um
maybe there was some sense that the
right postco they they maybe they were
opening up their tent they were kind of
okay with gay marriage perhaps they were
were allowing for more people to come in
that had felt alienated by them in the
past and maybe I'm and I'm just you know
working this out as we're talking I
perhaps felt
like there was some kind of place that I
could go where I felt like women were
respected and protected because the
other thing that I get online when I
talk about the right-wing has a problem
with um women is all people on the left
going oh the leopard's eating your face
I'm like [__] I don't want to hear
[__] from you you can't even Define what
a woman is you guys are raced women and
don't give me [__] about like the
leopards eating my face on the right
that that is ridiculous you guys you
have systematically reduced me to the
sum of my parts in in all of your
rhetoric and so I like I'm not hearing
any of that [__] from the people who are
now like oh that's what you get for
cozying up with the right wing but then
you do see the leopard EA in your
face and it's such a great point because
just to finish on this you go for
the I was thinking and with brand and I
thought it was so interesting and if you
look at what's happened kind of from
2014 but it really hit acceleration
point of 2016 we saw the dark side of
the left the kind of the Shadow side of
the left that's been coming more and
more to the fall with trans with you
know talking about Equity wanting to
punish but recently we've seen the mask
slip from the right as well where I've
seen people on the right I'm like oh God
you're you're actually awful this is
this is the problem I I have a friend
it's actually someone who's been a
subscriber my locals Community but we
become friends as you know you do with
people who are very active in the
community and he says the default
ideology in America is but the right you
know there's it's really just like but
the right but the right but then when
you see some of the stuff that comes
bubbling up under the surface you're
like but this is what people are afraid
of you know when people are saying and
again I think what I really landed on
post brand and and watching the
discourse around it was that no one
gives a [__] about women I I'll vote for
whatever party cares about women but I
don't see it coming I certainly don't
see it in the rhetoric on the right and
I I don't see it in at all from the left
whether they want to say that's true or
not I I disagree so yeah I feel I feel
actually more as we sit here today feel
more politically homeless than ever
before and it's interesting because when
we spoke last I was hearing from because
I occupy this very strange you know
Wasteland of the
center the it was a lot of women on the
left saying thank you for saying this I
can't say this thank you for speaking
out lately particularly when I tweeted
about you know the right has a a woman
problem um and it went and then someone
quot tweeted me and said maybe we don't
don't want um someone who slept with 100
dudes voting for The I'm like yeah why w
why W the
slot vote for us yeah we don't want your
[__]
vote what um okay so you're only made
yeah what exactly is the number too is
it 25 and then I can vote for the right
mean you're supposed to be a virgin
until marriage yeah and and I say this
by the way as someone who I think
probably on family stuff I am actually
quite socially conservative I do think
in an ideal world that is the best way
for people to get together and and it's
what I've done and it's been great for
me is all I'm saying right but I don't
think that uh attacking women for not
doing what you think is going to be
politically A very wise move but Bridget
I want to come back a little bit because
there's something that happened when the
brand allegations broke oh wait I want
to finish my point though sorry so now I
hear from conservative women thanking me
saying they can't say so that's been an
interesting shift is that it was women
on the left saying oh I can't say that
and now it's women on the right going
yeah we do have a problem I can't say it
I'll get piled on thank you for saying
it and so that that's been a weird
dynamic just anecdotally in my DMs which
is always very interesting to me well
very much on that point I apologize for
man interrupting earlier no it's
okay one of the things that happened
when those allegations broke was a lot
of people said something which on the
surface sounds correct which is if you
have allegations against somebody go to
the police right and these women didn't
go to the police and it's been 15 years
what do you want what what do you want
us to do about it right and I I that's a
Minefield that I don't really know how
to navigate exactly because if if you're
talking about criminal prosecution the
only only way criminal prosecution
happens is if you go to the police right
on the other hand having spoken to not
just you but other people who've been
raped that isn't how that works yeah
right so how do we how do we do how do
we solve that I mean and you look at
like the number of cases that actually
get prosecuted when they do go to the
police and the way that police often
treat victims and it it's it's not great
I don't I have no idea how you solve
that I think about this a lot because
did I at at the age that I was at I felt
that it was my fault so I think you
often feel in the moment I you know
what's really interesting is that I was
because of all this talk about the brand
stuff and then they were talking about
the journal and I was like did I write
about this I feel like I did and I have
a journal from it's like the darkest
time in my life all through it's it's a
crazy person's journal and I did write
about being sexually assaulted right
after it happened and it
was it was it was painful to read
Because I put so much blame on myself
and that's why I don't fault women for
10 years later when they're older and
more mature and have some hindsight to
say I was child I was I and I can look
at that girl and say I was a young girl
who I I blame myself for drinking I
blame myself for being like friendly
with the guy and I didn't want to tell
my mom because I felt like she would be
ashamed
and I I have a different perspective on
that than I had at at that exact like
having the ability to re look at what I
was thinking at that age is so eye
openening for me and for people going
well why didn't you just report like you
cannot know unless it's happen to you
how disruptive something like that is
and and how confused you are and how
betrayed and how ashamed or like the the
H
it's I and this guy was older he was
powerful all and I felt like no one
would believe me you know or they'd say
that it was my fault and I didn't want
to have to put myself through that and I
didn't want to have to expose myself
that way
so I don't I mean I that's why I thought
me too was so good like it it was the
good thing about me too because I felt
like my daughter was I would never want
her to feel that way about me but I felt
like she was coming into a world
where there was
more insight into that and
compassion um so I I felt like she was
coming into just a place where we had
come to somewhat more understanding of
what that does to a woman a man I mean
if you see the way that they talk about
women being sexually assaulted imagine
if you're a man who's gone through that
and how hard it would be for you to come
forward people don't talk enough about
that either it's not like only women
experience this men are violated and
molested and all kinds of things and if
you're a man and you see the way that
people are speaking about this as if
it's their fault or whatever you're the
chances that you're ever going to come
forward are even less than if you're a
woman and so I felt like that was
changing and I actually thought that was
a good thing people were having this
conversation they were seeing how many
of their sisters mothers friends have
experienced this and then now it feels
like we're regressing again you know it
feels like we're going we're going back
into into the time where women again you
when you see this discourse occurring
and everyone from I think Jordan
Peterson even came out people that you
kind of look to and respect on some
level perhaps particularly if you're
independent or right-wing because
everything's freaking partisan now
um you see that and you're like uh I'm I
don't you know suddenly you start asking
yourself if
you're if you if it is your fault or if
it is something that you should be
ashamed of or if you it is because you
are promiscuous and that's never an
excuse you know you can that's just
never an excuse you can't use that no
matter how many people someone slept
with
and I don't don't know how you fix that
because it seems like it's getting
actually worse now so I'm not sure you
know I I would encourage I can only say
that and I've talked about this before
on Rogan I was kind of able to help
someone through this when they went
through it themsel around exactly the
same circumstances and age that I was
and we went and got um a Rabe kit done
and all that stuff and she didn't have
to you know press charges right away but
she could have and she didn't want to
because she didn't know how to tell same
thing but um I encouraged her to talk to
her mom about it which she eventually
did and she did something that I didn't
do which was just taking the step to
even go get a rape kit done
and I don't know I it's something that
looking back should I have done that
yeah I should have but at the time could
I have did I feel like I had anyone who
would take me or I didn't so and if a
bunch of women came out and you know
came were saying that this person did
something to them I would absolutely
come forward even if it
meant all the stuff that comes along
with that however many years later I
would definitely bring my journal and
and stand behind those women because I
know that happened to me but you know
there's a lot of women who will say that
I it was selfish of me not to do
something because they could have gone
on to rape other women and I I have to
again I I live with that now looking
back but at the
time I that wasn't even like a
consideration I wasn't even I was like
how do I get through the next day how do
I just I started drinking alcoholically
almost immediately and then Doing Hard
drug it was like I wasn't thinking about
like anything other than other than the
pain that I was in and and surviving it
yeah and and moving through it and so
yeah I don't know I don't know it's a
weird thing that social media has done
where everyone is pretending to be
empathetic but actually everyone's a
[__] psychopath right
do you know what I mean like there's a
distinct La lack of empathy in the idea
that you know well if a
woman was raped then if she has to go to
the police otherwise it didn't happen
right like you if that was your da you
think that you really think that if your
daughter came to you and said that and
she did do do you know you wouldn't be
like that with your daughter you
wouldn't say that about her if you if
you're 40 years old you have a
20-year-old daughter and she comes to
you and says actually when this thing
happened 5 years a AG or whatever you
wouldn't be like why don't you go to the
police and now imagine that it's a huge
star and you know that if your daughter
comes forward it's it's going to be the
entire right-wing ecosystem is coming
after this person now and that's the
other thing that was bothering me about
all of this is that I felt like the
women who came forward were damned if
they did and damned if they didn't if
they came forward they would be like
riding Russell's coattails and trying to
get famous if they remained Anonymous
they're just hiding in the shadows and
they're they're liars and so there's no
way for these people to win in this
situation and I don't know whether it's
true or not it might not be but I still
feel like in we cannot deny him due
process anymore than we should still at
least give some benefit of the doubt to
people who are making these allegations
and in fact people say oh it's because
he's moved over to the you know he's
like whatever confronting the Matrix or
whatever the [__] they say like he this
guy is a threat to you know everyone the
the whatever they're saying well
wouldn't that make it even more
dangerous for these people to come
forward then wouldn't it make it more
they have now this whole ecosystem
coming after them as opposed to when he
was just famous and
and and then the other weird thing that
was such a paradox was they're like well
he was protected by his tribe and he I'm
like but now you're doing the same thing
so like he was protected by the
establishment and he was protected by
these people and they nobody came after
him and they buried all this stuff and
that all might be true but now can you
see that you're potentially doing
exactly the same thing it's that was a
it was weird it's like oh they were
protecting him when he was was their
dude I'm like and now he's your
dude and now you're protecting him like
I see no difference when did we become
so judgmental because the whole one of
the
main one of the main sort of ethoses of
the left was don't judge other people M
you know everybody we're liberals
Everybody's Free To Live the Life that
they want then the left became super
judgmental the right are very very
Christian the majority of them you know
super Christian you what did Jesus say
Jud judge not L ye be judged but then
they're like yeah let's judge them and
you go hang on are you not tur turning
your back on your own ways of being do
you do you understand yeah that it's
it's weird to
watch what's happening on the right is
interesting to me right now because the
algorithm it's like they're being red
builded
and for lack of a better word it just
feels like they're being the incentives
are kind of pulling them to the in the
same way that we saw on the left the
extreme faction that did not represent
most people pulled the discourse to the
left and left a lot of people a drift or
or you know that idea like I didn't
leave the left left me behind I see the
right kind of it's like this negative
feedback loop that's just pulling
pulling them to the right because you're
seeing people who like to talk about you
know the Matrix
shortless um like making millions of
dollars and really capturing this young
male audience that everybody wants and
so I can't help but this think that this
new weird like in kind of conserv
conserva con discourse about body C and
stuff I'm like you guys had so much
Goodwill postco and post wokeism so much
Goodwill and you cannot win you just you
you're determined to just like you're
going to start now policing women being
like obsessed with who women are
sleeping with it's it's it's freaking
creepy and weird guys like now you're
going back to the right that I remember
I'm like oh there you are that's right
that's right I remember except now you
have no God to your point now you have
now you're like a Godless version of the
Moral Majority which is basically what
the left became it's creepy it is it is
do you remember James o who we had on he
I I don't think it's his own line he
quoted someone he said if you're if you
fear the religious right just wait till
you meet the post-religious
right we're we're meeting them yeah and
we're seeing them and and the thing that
I find terrifying is the right were
what one of the main particularly in
this country pushing back against the
extremes of trans ideology you know
which everyone in this room I'm sure is
just absolutely finds absolutely ad hor
the medicalization of children is
disgusting yeah your your prime minister
came out pretty yeah yeah in the UK
we're actually winning the argument Turf
Island Turf Island yeah we wi in the
argument and then you see certain people
coming out in the on the American and
they you know they've always been
pushing back on it and I've been like
that's good and then you start to go how
long will it be until you come after the
gays because when you win this fight as
the fight will be one because it's so
awful what they're doing how soon until
be until you're like you know what you
know gay marriage it was a slippery slow
yeah well they're already talking about
gay marriage but it seems to me like if
that if that is taken to its logical
conclusion you say the ride that I
remember the ride that I remember is the
one that Carlin and Hicks were pushing
against right right they're going to be
censoring people's speech before long
they're like they spent 20 years
chanting about Free Speech right and
before you know it we're going to be
like you can't say this you can't joke
about that yeah that's coming yeah it
does seem like anyone who has power um
wants to censor censor people and
everyone seems to think that they're
immune to that you know they're like oh
well the censorship is coming and it is
and that's the that is the that is where
I have a where I feel very conflicted
because the institutional power lies on
the left and there is no doubt that you
have big Tech in cahoots with the
government in cahoots with Academia and
the media and Hollywood and
entertainment and all of these huge
institutions School everything um
working to be Pro censorship and pro all
this weird flip-flopping that we've seen
and you guys have discussed adnasium
what so I understand the kind of oh and
you guys are why the right is becoming
more extreme and they're like well these
centrists like ourselves are freaking
useless be in some ways we are they're
right they're not entirely wrong in
saying in this fight you have to if you
so they're talking about women being
[__] and Body Count but they're
sterilizing children like can't can't
don't you eventually have to take a
stand and say this one's worse than this
one and I wrestle with this you know I
I've been it's probably the biggest
criticism that I receive that I don't
think is entirely wrong but then when I
get piled on by the right and see that
other side of them where
it's uh unsettling
and it just feels like misogyny is
everywhere you know I hate to use that
term but it does feel like there's this
misogynistic impulse that's like wants
to tell me what to do with my body and
what I can and shame me for my past and
um but is that do they have any power do
they have any actual power see I
disagree with you about us being useless
because I think I'm glad the the
look countries are different and
America's politics is very different but
the reason we've been successful on the
trans issue in the UK is actually
because more moderate people have been
speaking up about it right right so when
JK Rowling comes for but Douglas Murray
sorry to interrupt you will argue that
it's because we don't have somebody like
Oprah coming forward and speaking out on
this that doesn't give people permission
in the states to even push back who are
moderate and might feel like like they
do in the UK well but that's exactly
what I'm saying but but people like us
who are clearly not on the right
strongly or on the left strongly
providing a space for that conversation
to be heard and people with much bigger
platforms like a Jer rolling there's a
leftwing labor MP who we we mentioned on
Rogan Rosie Duffield you know you have
people speaking out who are who are
immune as much as is possible to the the
isms and the phobias or whatever that's
very important because most normal
people They don't want to side with the
people who are on the extreme edges
shouting the loudest they want to see a
a position they believe in reflected in
moderate sensible conversation and then
they feel more empowered to be like oh
yeah I'm against this ideology as well
so I don't think we're useless actually
at all I think the reason you say that
is it's not the most Pleasant place to
be the center is always the place of
greatest tend
I I agree but I do think at a certain
point um there
there
there's I would have to choose a a side
in terms I don't think they the the
reasonable moderate Center feels
represented so in absence of having any
political representation you are forced
to kind of choose a lesser of two evils
and I think many PE what the AR arent
would be that people of the the IDW or
the classical liberals or whatever
whatever space we occupy the center
default to voting for the left I don't
know that that's actually true in
practice yeah I don't either um but when
it comes to choosing a president which I
actually there's not many options you
know I guess I could vote third party
just out of out of some sense of my
morality but as these fights become more
I was joking on dumpster fire just this
week I was like if Gavin Nome becom gets
the election I might have to vote for
Trump which is something I and I don't
even know if that's if I could hold my
nose and vote for him because I find him
so just reprehensible um as a as a
person but and I think Character Matters
but the but then when it comes down to
these kinds of fights
like pushing back against sterilizing
kids what do you do well I'll tell you
my answer I'll tell you my answer which
is there are some things I live in the
UK there I mean that's part of it but
there are some things that are so
abominable that they are just more
important and therefore I will hold my
nose with both hands if I have to is is
the truth and I will vote for whoever is
going to OS that that's actually one of
the dangers in in what this is doing
because it it forces a lot of people to
vote for parties that they don't
actually want to vote for right and the
more you the left pushes the extremes
into the mainstream the more you're
going to people are going to be like oh
yeah you know what you know I don't care
about women's rights [__] it you know
this is more important The Border's
being invaded right yeah yeah and and
and it's but that if if if the leftwing
parties refuse to have borders want to
sterilize children Etc I'm sorry I will
vote for Donald Trump without if I lived
in this country I'll vote for a
right-wing party in the UK without any
hesitation I will not hesitate for a
second because it's [__] evil yeah
it's evil yeah and and there's a lot of
people who would say that the the stuff
that's happening I mean January said
we're touching all the buttons today and
now we're talking about January 6
um we'll get back to the episode in a
minute but first we want to tell you
about our sponsor Verso in our recent
interview with Tim Urban he said we
should be talking about longevity and
Longevity science researchers like the
biologist David Sinclair have recently
made some fascinating discoveries on how
to mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that is why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products of hold the
potential to increase your longevity and
one of their products I take every day
is called cell beinging cell being helps
combat aging by increasing something
called NAD Plus in your body NAD is
arguably the most important molecule in
your body high NAD levels improve your
metabolism repair damaged DNA and
increase energy production in your brain
immune system and muscles but as you
grow old your body's NAD levels go down
and you can't take NAD as a supplement
because it's too big for your cells to
absorb that's why Vero cell being
contains nmn Resveratrol and TMG these
three molecules work together to
increase NAD plus levels if you want to
read more about this check out the
scientific research Linked In the
description of the video plus Verso
publishes third party testing on every
batch of its products to guarantee that
you're getting exactly what you're
paying for so if you want to join us you
can get 15% off by going to
v.o that's
v.s o and use code trigger to save 15%
of your order now back to the
interview I was saying I will vote for
the right part of and I was saying
people would argue that the stuff that's
happening on the right is a
constitutional crisis and that if he got
power he would never leave and that
there's you know Fascism and and so and
whether or not but that isn't true
though Bridget he's not a fascist yeah
no so we have this is where this is
where the thing comes in is like the
reason I will I will as someone who is
in our kind of politically homeless
space vote for somebody on the right is
because the things they say about the
right are not true right right whereas
the things that people say about the
left are true so for example in the UK
um they call soel braan who's a
descendant of immigrants racist and
xenophobic for wanting to prevent people
from getting into boats illegally and
coming into the country in a country
which now spends about $10 million a day
on hotels for illegal immigrants right
now that's true MH is it does that make
her a fascist I don't think so does
thinking that there are men and there
are women and you can't change sex by in
ination is that making you a fascist no
right so in my opinion you have to go
down the list of the issues and go is
what is being said about the right TR is
what is being said about the left Tru
and in my opinion right now when I look
at that I mean the American right yeah
is going loopy as we've talked about but
they're not they're not actually fascist
right they're not actually going to
suspend democracy they're not actually
going to do any of the things January
the 6th was not an Insurrection it was
bad it's bad that that happened it's not
a good thing but it wasn't an attempt to
seize power right so just because the
left says certain things about the right
doesn't mean it's true just because the
right says certain things about the left
doesn't mean it's true we have to
actually look at what they're saying and
go is this true yes is this true no and
play issue by issue do you know what I
mean yeah yeah yeah and but then I start
thinking about uh like breitbart's whole
politics are Downstream of culture which
the right has really embraced and why
they try they're trying to be more
culturally
persuasive and if that is actually true
why they would engage in all this silly
um discourse around like my Instagram
feed there was one last night that I was
showing my cousin and my and we were
dying laughing and it's a woman and she
has like a craft mac and cheese bag and
she flicks it and it's like when you're
a Suburban mom but you have a
questionable pass like you used to flick
like a baggie
and I was like my whole Instagram feed
is to Burman moms who joke about how
they used to be party girls and now
their moms living their best life that
is the entirety granted it's all being
targeted at me because that's also me
but that but that is also just the
suburbs and kind of where we are why
would you why would you Al even risk
alienating this these people who you
could potentially bring over to your
side because I think they're worried
about about their children which
ultimately I think will win out but I
don't even know why you would risk it
with like a silly body count discourse
and all this like [__] shaming and and
and the the weird stuff we're seeing
kind of um popping up but do you think
and I thought about this a lot do you
think it's about disgust because when
you get to the extremes of the political
Spectrum the extreme left disgusted by
the right they go these people are
racists they're B they're disgusting
they're fascists they're Nazis and you
can hear when they when they talk about
them they they really feel they almost
taste the emotions and then when you get
to the right you know they're transing
the kids you know they're disgusting
they're communist they want to abolish
our country you know all of the that
that's what we're getting from both
sides it's like visceral disgust and yet
it's not what I experience I think the
best thing that's happened to me being a
sub living in the suburbs and being
weirdly one foot very in the discourse
and one foot not is that most people
have no idea what we're talking about
they're not they might if it's invading
their schools I think this is why you're
seeing a lot of people leaving New York
uh LA and going to states that are more
purple or red and but otherwise it's
like they talk about how the pool is
down in the HOA you know Facebook group
and what their kids are going to be for
Halloween and and this is only again
only my experience I don't I don't think
normal people
are I think the they are more in the
center they're just naturally people
have different ideological beliefs and
they are still neighbors and friends and
go to barbecues together so I'm not this
is something that I've been really
fascinated with lately too is observing
how it seems like the very online people
and that discourse is is getting away
from the people who are not very online
and living very much in the world in in
kind of an accelerated way it seems like
there the realities are splitting
completely like the language that people
use who are very online and the things
that they talk about no if I walked
around my suburb and knocked on every
door how many people do you think would
have ever heard of bronze Bronze Age
pervert I don't I don't think I've heard
of exactly and you guys are very online
and this is a person who's very online
who's got had a 30 number 33 on Amazon
for a minute at least bestselling book
that um and people talk about this like
it's anart argument that's that my point
is I think we're arguing about things
online and they'll feel like they have
to
um like push back against his arguments
or somehow contend with this and like no
one's ever heard of this person other
than people online people who are very
online and that separation is really
interesting to me because I'm not
sure what that looks like even in a year
as as we enter into the because the
things that I do hear about in the
suburbs from people who are now choosing
to homeschool their kids and pulling
them out is the G the gender stuff and
as Helen Joyce was just on Walkins
welcome our podcast and she's like this
breaks everything it was so eye open you
know the way she's so clear and
Brilliant and just saying how it's
breaking everything it's just it it it
really does it's the tip of The Spar
which which is why everyone spends so
much time talking about it and it breaks
democracies it breaks Norms it breaks
families apart and you see people
wrestling with not wanting their
children exposed to this crap and how if
the minute that it happens in a school
they're pulling their kid out of school
and starting a homeschooling pod and
even people on the left or Libertarians
are starting their own little preschools
because they don't want their kids
exposed to this so that is the one area
where I actually feel
like it's it's
um it's really bled into reality MH
MH but you know what you've just said
really gives me hope Bridget because it
really really does be because there's
always going to be these people who on
are very online like all of us are but
the fact that there's the majority who
are just living their lives raising
their family
yeah having their
careers having relationships that's what
life really is about to me there is
nothing more wonderful than when I go
for a meal with a friend or I I go for a
drink and they don't want to talk about
this and I'm like oh that's amazing you
know what we all talk about the cost of
food yeah that's what everyone talks
about everywhere how expensive food is
every single city state that I go in
when I was back East with my family when
I was on the West Coast with all my
family out there recently when I I it's
like everywhere I go that's what
everyone's talking about is how
expensive food has got and G gas it's
really important and yet we're being
gaslit and told like oh everything's
great biomics is amazing and like you
guys are just imagining that you're poor
you know it's it's a weird that's what
real people are talking about but I
disagree with you guys though the elite
discourse is always separated from the
ordinary person and always has been and
yeah that is what determines reality I
mean I don't know if you saw this post
BLM the top 100 standard and pause
corporations did you see this no uh they
made three uh 300,000 new hires 6% of
them were
white
300,000,000 new hires 6% of them were
white right so once this ideology
becomes embedded in institutions and
corporations and schools Etc the fact
that Joe blogs down the road is doing is
barbecuing and not paying attention to
any of it does not mean that Joe's blog
Joe blogs down the road is not getting
hired for a job on Merit his children
aren't being taught trans ideology in
school Etc this Elite Discord this is
always it's always the way the
Bolsheviks were a tiny minority right
right but they were motivated they were
United they were driven they were
passionate they had a strong ideology
this is why I've always opposed wokness
because look at look at what it's done
yeah look at what it's done and so the
fact that ordinary people aren't paying
attention good for their mental health I
guess right but it's not protecting them
from being affected by it in real life
and it's not just the trans issue the
rracial isation of society is a big
problem yeah it's a big problem uh the
the I don't know if you saw there was
this amazing piece about how uh the
title I think was complex systems won't
survive the competency crisis the
competence crisis and it's about how
artificial diversity essentially uh is
causing airplane accidents and all of
this other stuff because people aren't
being hired CU they're good at the job
they're being hired because they take
boxes these things affect real real
world stuff it's it's the only reason I
care about it you know I I've never been
interested in having online fights about
things that don't matter but this stuff
affects reality it really does yeah no I
absolutely I'm not saying it doesn't but
I don't I don't
know
then then yeah I think that is why
people are increasingly becoming
radicalized because if you are pushing
back against this this reorganization of
the world in reality and you
are you know there there it's gone
pretty
extreme
you and it's all about power then the
argument that a lot of people on the
right make is they have to play these
are the new rules but then that feels
like um that's an abdication of
responsibility in my well it feels
very like uh okay so now yeah you
abdicate every all your principles too
for power no and now nobody and now
people are looking around and there's
sure there's people fighting for power
but there's no real leadership who's
who's leading it was nice to hear your
prime minister I we saying on dumpster
fire I'm like finally an adult in the
room and we shouldn't get bullied into
believing that people can be any sex
they want to be they can't a man is a
man and a woman is a woman that's just
common
sense like the one world leader who's
willing to come out and say boys and
girls are different and we shouldn't be
bullied into believing otherwise which
is insane that it's even got to this
point and he's being called a transphobe
a bigot a fascist Etc
and I think it's but that's leadership
to me you know so I don't see very much
leadership I do see a lot of people
jockeying for power and I think the
incentive structures online around the
discourse are generally you know get
attention and get clicks it's not
necessarily what's good for America no
we we all joke what's bad for society is
good for us yeah um which is not good
you know that's it's hard for me to I
don't I try very hard not to lean into a
lot of that outrage cycles and clicks
and whatnot because I don't want to I
don't want to be a part of the problem
and so do we we tried to do that on that
happy note Bridget we're going to go to
locals in a second okay and ask
questions from our supporters before we
do we always end with the same questions
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be nothing we all need to
shut up
except us obviously subscribe
yeah we should all take one of those
vapas meditations where you don't talk
for 10 days imagine if the world just
did that and everybody just went for 10
days and just and Silent we we'd either
come out better or just significantly
insane
insane totally out of our minds yeah so
nothing would change then yeah exactly
would stay insane yeah all right guys
head on over to locals where we continue
the conversation including your
questions he will shamelessly and
sociopathically lie to continue to gain
power he's a very disciplined
psychopath he's Trump he's he's much
better than
[Music]
him